should we just jump right in Just Jump
Right In let's just jump right into it
let's jump into it what's up YouTube are
you rolling Christian oh hey we're live
what's up everybody uh hey we are live
now
yeah Ren went to Texas to sit in Jake's
office to record the podcast
I'm here sitting remotely in Jake's
office you can't tell the difference
right now
right now because I still have covid
kind of I mean it's like the very tail
end of it very tail end of it I don't
feel any symptoms anymore right now
I'm feeling all right yeah we have your
cardboard Effigy yeah oh my God it's had
every once in a while I love that thing
just because of how different it looks
depending on how you rotate it
yeah here I'll just wear it for the
there you go it's like you're here it's
so scary when you put it right at the
camera because it looks like it just
kind of disappears and you see my eyes
through my face
from my camera I see these little white
dots of eyes but I think it's just
reflecting off of the cardboard a little
actually you should be able to see my
eyes through it if I do this right this
is probably not the best thing for a
podcast which is an audio only thing but
like If You're Gonna Shine your light
through it
well hey how's it going everyone Thanks
for tuning in to the corridorcast uh I
have been out for the last couple weeks
uh if we wanted to catch up on any of
that and now I'm back in the studio
are you
I'm in Jake's office that we've already
established
yeah if you've had covet for the last
two weeks
no just the last one week which I got
from Jan driving spending two days in
the truck with Jan driving back from
burning man after getting stranded at
Burning Man for an additional couple
days
it was a great time
we're debating whether or not people
actually want to hear Burning Man
stories I know I I'm I'll I'll say on
the matter is that I think everyone
should should try it at some point in
their lives it's a crazy experience it
was my first time
and there's no other way to describe it
you have to kind of experience it
did you did you burn the man no
it rained too much
ah there's no Burning Man
wedding
wedding man
no it uh because it poured rain I it was
an awesome like first four days of the
trip but then on Friday it started
raining and then it didn't stop raining
we got like three months of rain in less
than a day and so it's a dry lake bed so
the entire place just flooded half an
inch or more on the first day so there's
mud everywhere and it's not mud it's
Clay it's this fine clay that just
sticks to everything and so you'd be
walking around with like five pounds of
mud on each of your feet and so my knees
were super sore after a few days of that
and I couldn't figure out why until I
realized I've basically been walking
around with ankle weights uh but yeah so
that was that was wild that was an
experience not nearly as bad as the
media made it seem to be but
I got out in one piece it wasn't too bad
uh too big of a deal but Jan was
starting to feel sick like on the last
day and
um then I spent two days in the car with
him trying to get out of there
I'm sure a lot of people got it there it
was probably going around I mean
probably yeah although I mean it's hard
to say because it is mostly Outdoors
it's like it's an outdoors thing like I
slept in a tent for the week
um so camping and being outside is like
one of the safest places from covid
that's true but somehow I got it so
maybe I know nothing
she could have had it all week and not
been symptomatic but I mean you must
have gotten it there I mean as far as
I'm aware this is the first time I've
had covid so I mean I may have had it
and just never known it but every time
I've tested for it in the past it's
always come up negative
yeah well I'm glad well you're not back
in the office yet so I can't say I'm
glad you're back because you're not back
yet
a lot yeah
I'm glad you're alive you know yeah I'm
glad you're not still muddy I guess yeah
I'm not worried about you getting muddy
exactly uh
so I feel like I've just been completely
out of the the bubble of corridor for
the last couple weeks
uh and I'm curious how you guys are
doing Griffin how are you man
I'm doing well dude I'm you know well
hydrated
um you know my my macros are looking
good
um
uh things have been going smooth for me
around here and uh also been venturing
into some exciting art and music
territory outside of work so yeah last
couple weeks have been have been really
nice uh yeah how you guys doing thank
you good you can't you can't mention
this new art and music territory without
delving a little bit deeper yeah I want
to know more
oh well um I've uh
I did I did a little portrait a little
digital painting portrait and uh I'm
doing some preliminary work to dip my
feet into making clothing making like a
tire and merchandise just like a fun
little thing
and then uh on a whim I
um started making EDM again for the
first time in like 12 years I started
making like drum and bass and house
music so
something about that I'm very curious
yeah like what does that entail for you
like are you are you do you have like a
mixing board
I have a very very limited setup at home
that's mostly digital I have uh studio
monitors I have like a two octave midi
keyboard and then just like a bunch of
vsts digital like plugins and stuff and
uh I check all my mixes in the car and
on my TV as you do
there may not be a small EP uh coming
out later this year or next year I have
no idea but really it's been fun getting
into it so oh yeah all right I think the
theme of this podcast is gonna be
everyone's hobby art projects laughs
that's cool yeah
what's uh what's your artist name
Griffin do you have one yet
um
no I've been I've been like
thinking about it like there's a couple
there's one that I might want to do for
my like goth Post Punk project okay like
and then but I was also thinking about
like Griffin Thorne is like like why
waste that name yeah it's a pretty good
name it's a pretty good name yeah
Griffin if you weren't if you hadn't
gotten to the realm of like
you know art and digital art and graphic
art and all that kind of stuff what do
you think you would be doing right now I
would like professionally yeah I would a
hundred percent be like uh a ski bum I
would be like I could answer like
working uh being like a lift operator
um just like living uh at the mountain
and just snowboarding all day every day
that's absolutely what I would have done
awesome making drum and bass on the side
yeah maybe yeah
that's that sounds pretty great Griffin
I would love to go snowboarding with you
I would love that so much
oh dude let's do I'm I'm getting back
into it this season
um
dude let's do it we should we should go
together I'm super down 100 down deal
you gotta deal man I've been wanting to
get back into snowboarding for so long
I snowboarded for like half an hour once
I decided I'd rather go back to skiing
yeah it's intense man I was like last
winter I was all gung-ho about it for
the first time I'm like I can one wheel
now so I can snowboard now yeah
it is not the same thing it's like
really scary learning how to switch
sides as you're going down yeah yeah
because you just have to kind of fling
yourself and like get the like you're
like all right I'm just gonna turn into
it now I just hope momentum you know is
there on your side but yeah my legs have
never been as tired ever skiing
yeah the scoreboard seriously it was
like that was the worst because you're
constantly having like sit down get back
upset you're just doing like hundreds of
squats a day
yeah and just like the I don't know with
skiing I feel like since you're straight
you don't have to use as many muscles to
stay like you obviously have to use your
legs as like Springs and like you know
absorb your shock but the snowboarding
there's a whole other element of like
don't fall into the mountain or away
from the mountain that I think adds to
the the just exhaustion so I want to try
it again though it was definitely easier
for me to learn skiing like I can ski oh
and it's easier to learn skiing but I
feel like once you get through that
initial hump of learning how to
snowboard like once you can actually
finally do a turn it all just like opens
up totally and then it becomes exactly
like one Wheeling yeah I I like kind of
hit that at the End by like my last run
I was like too tired to go on but I'm
like okay I can like if I were to come
back tomorrow or like in a week once I
recovered yeah I'd be I'd have a great
time yeah and then 10 years later cut
too although the biggest difference
between snowboarding and one Wheeling is
the fact that a snowboard can go
sideways it slides which like we we
tested that one electric skateboard
several years back that had like the
caster wheels on the bottom of it that
was also motorized it could like skate
back and forth like a snowboard what a
weird
I still have it I keep thinking about
trying to learn how to ride it again it
was hard it was very hard
yeah Nick do you have any like side art
projects you've been working on outside
of making the movie side art projects I
mean mostly just the movie Man any side
art projects yeah I know feature length
yeah I mean no big deal my side my side
thing what about your what about this
this little Channel you talked about oh
man well yeah so okay wait wait can I
can I guess what the name is yeah yeah I
guess
uh Nick is Matic
I like that yeah
new numismatic the Noom is met
um now it's it's called history at home
I right now I only do coin videos but
maybe we'll expand that history at home
history at home that's cool I'm here at
home we're doing history talking history
when did you start this channel I
started it um like probably just about
two years ago and I've made about six
five or six videos only but they're long
videos dude it's like like cleaning a
coin is a long video so it takes me
forever to edit it it's like you know I
haven't had a lot of time to put into it
so it's like if I have an extra hour
like once a week I'll like just you know
cut it up but it's fun man I get to like
it show people a satisfying process and
that makes great YouTube content and
there's an audience for It Whatever
whatever you're cleaning on YouTube
people want to watch that like dude you
can make anything clean on YouTube and
it'll be like worth worth So you you're
starting to get a little audience
there's there's people that are watching
my videos yeah I mean it's like enough I
think I have like 5 000 subscribers
oh yeah you know it's like a slow
trickle like a couple like there's views
but it's not like a business or anything
but sure yeah like it's it's more just
for me to be able to like put these uh
these little projects out and have them
live somewhere and be able to just like
just uh gush to people about the history
and if they want to watch it they can
it's there so yeah I've been really
curious what it's like to try to start a
YouTube channel these days okay because
like this thing I've been thinking about
talk about on the podcast and like
because you know we obviously have not
had to study YouTube channel in a long
time
um but you know when we started YouTube
like we could rely on like visual
effects like Digital Cinema being a hard
thing to do so there weren't a lot of
people yeah use that to stand out
I feel like you need to stand out in
some way for people to like notice you
and unless you're like stunningly
gorgeous or incredibly charismatic like
you gotta have some sort of weird idea
or unique thing but like yeah I wonder
like if we were to start a YouTube
channel today like could we make it like
would it would it grow as fast as it did
back then at the same speed would it be
harder would it be easier
you know like but you're you got it you
got a YouTube channel you started well
you just need that little like I think
yeah you can't just like expect to make
a YouTube channel that like you right
unless you are charismatic or good
looking or both is better but if if you
have like something like like cleaning
an ancient coin for instance you know
it's a kind of unique thing it's a
somewhat simple text but not many people
are up to it right and there's also
something like kind of there's like a
story there it's like history being
uncovered like what can this tell me so
you just gotta have something compelling
to watch you know it's like exactly
there's there's a lot of people out
there so it doesn't have to be super
broad a super Niche thing can still have
a lot of uh people to watch it because
it's still compelling for those people
yeah yeah and it's been really fun like
kind of
not worrying about like all the the
rules and kind of processes we we go
through here as part of our job and part
of our a little cathartic in that way
like like no I don't have to try to I
can do whatever I want but it's a video
yeah it's like I want to you know keep
that consistency and the kind of content
and like also having the knowledge of
the rules to break them you know after
is good so it's like yeah like you want
to have a little bit of consistency I've
definitely applied a lot of the
thumbnail principles that we we but like
practice here so yeah it's been fun but
I haven't oh gosh I need it you're like
I don't have to cut this for time I have
one dude everything is fine sick this
awesome uh Egyptian coin and it's
beautiful and I just gotta put it up I
just gotta edit it it's gonna take like
five hours to edit or more so someday
someday someday yeah Griffin how do you
like discover new YouTube channels like
what do you what do you think it'd be
like trying to start oh like what advice
would you have as somebody who deals
with one of the most crucial aspects of
making videos which is like the actual
thumbnail and title of them
oh man you know I I find that the
channels I end up gravitating toward are
often like
it's not necessarily having a gimmick or
being super super original but it's
people who can add something new to a
conversation like I'll find a cooking
channel maybe like just making something
up a cooking channel where they aren't
like cooking crazy stuff but they have
like one unique thing they add to it
like um this is this is not a niche
Channel but like tasting history that
channel is great because it's like you
know it's a cooking show and the host is
charismatic but if it was just those two
things I probably wouldn't stick around
but he has that other thing that he can
bring to the table that no one else is
which is the like the historical aspect
and
I think if you can like bring something
new like if you want to start a Cooking
Channel or a music channel that's great
and if I think if you want to stand out
figure out what you uniquely as a person
can bring to that sphere and then make
sure when you're marketing it you you do
the best to get that across which is a
tall order but I think from what I can
see that's what attracts me the most to
new channel that's like almost Universal
like that's like a rule you could really
like it's a there's like pillars it's
like one is having some Authority on a
subject you're talking about right some
professional experience the other is
charisma being able to be on camera and
like being comfortable with that yeah
translate like that
and then consistency I think and just
like making stuff that people know
there's going to be content there to
watch and like you're not jumping around
too much like that's all you need to
make a really good YouTube channel that
has everything it needs to succeed I
think yeah like good and sorry go ahead
no I mean it's like you see even on Tick
Tock it's like people watch like experts
on little green screens you know down
the corner and just like watching [__]
and like they don't even really add much
they just like hey like check out this
thing that anyone can read on Wikipedia
well yep here you go here's the map and
I'm pointing it's like people want the
expert though to tell them that expert
yeah what's worse than that of the ones
where it's just like it's a side-by-side
like Stitch and it's just a personal one
they're just like making faces and
reacting to the content without
literally saying a word at all it's just
the it's like why is this even here
I don't know it just adds that extra
element I guess for people like to be
able to connect with stuff it's like I
need to watch someone else connecting
with this to know how I should connect
maybe yeah I guess I mean it's like it's
like being able to go to the comments
section without having to go into the
comments yeah yeah true right there on
the video it's right there it is
everybody's just taking their cues from
Japanese like daytime audience live
stream yeah
other people watching it too yeah really
freaking weird but
I mean yeah dude those are the best
channels on YouTube or like those weird
little like crafting or like education
channels where it's like they they just
give you one unique insight or like it
at least one perspective on something uh
that's really cool I always think about
like the old school movie producer being
like people like zombie movies we need
to get zombies I also need I need some
boats people like boat movies and it's
like I always think about like that's
something like this is so like reductive
like it doesn't matter how good a movie
is and like the more time I've spent
like on YouTube the market realize like
those old film producers are right when
they're like oh we need a boat movie
it's like yeah actually if you do just
like put a boat in your movie and it's a
movie about a boat it doesn't matter how
good it is there is a chunk of
population that's like I love boat wait
really no anything anything happening
just okay not just boats I mean it's not
a good Boat Moving for you there is
boats are very important this is
actually these are these are recordings
from the James Cameron conversations
before Titanic came out but yeah but
like I find that this really true where
it's like if you're starting a YouTube
channel you know or starting some
anything like if there's a community
there if you can truly tap into a
community with like knowledge and like
authenticity
like it'll grow no matter what as long
as you bring that authenticity and
knowledge yeah like the the guy who um
uh co-produced helped us with our line
producing on the movie his name is David
Lynch he when we started out the film
wait
I'm sorry Michael David Lynn
Castle or something he goes by the witch
so like I literally always forget what
his first name is he has two first names
so it's like one of those things anyway
he's an example of like someone who was
like okay I love playing Magic the
Gathering
um and he just started this channel like
three years ago when we started
production and like you know we we talk
every once in a while and I'd give him
some advice on like consistency and like
you know here's like maybe with your
thumbnail or here's how you start a
video to get to the point and it was
like
he just did it and he started making
these campaigns with his friends and it
freaking blew up and now he's like one
of the biggest Magic the Gathering
channels on YouTube and it's it's really
cool to see a success story where it's
like this guy was like hey I have a
vision I have one like Niche kind of
community like you were saying and then
I have like a unique spin on that that
isn't there yeah
um and yeah I mean
that channel is still I think pretty
successful I don't know I mean yeah he
doesn't need advice from me anymore
let's just say that I mean I feel I feel
like the biggest like
you know person the biggest success I've
seen from somebody who's at quarter
who's launched a channel is probably
Danny Gonzalez oh man yeah yeah I think
he's working for like some companies
making Facebook videos and then that
company folded and he joined us he was
with us for like like what was like five
or six months or something like that
maybe it was like just shy of half a
year because Clinton joined on
yep and we made some really great videos
like that I'm buying a tank video is one
of my favorites and then the pub G
mobile video as well yeah yeah it's good
videos not Spider-Man
world's longest lightsaber that's right
that's right that's a good one yeah man
wasn't that the most viewed video
yeah it is video 170 million views I
like the idea you had of world's
smallest lightsaber
small it's like cancerous it just like
kills me one cell at a time
yeah
no it's crazy though because Danny he
like he left us and became like actually
a pretty big YouTuber like doing really
well for himself we saw him at the
streamies last December
uh it's like Danny whoa yeah he's huge
he's bigger than Corridor which is you
know which is crazy
um and it's cool to see but like I
remember when he was like Hey You know
guys I'm thinking about parting ways I
kind of want to focus on this YouTube
channel it's like this the YouTube
channel he's talking about it's like
getting more views in our channel it's
like yeah it sounds good Danny you go do
that
happen
I'd love to see that consistency yeah
you know well there every time and and
remember how good ideas too when he
joined us and we started doing skits
with us initially like our audience
didn't like him at all they thought he
was like really mean they thought he was
like really a loser okay
yeah he's playing yeah but like the fact
that people didn't like I don't know
it was like the pre Markiplier that's
right and he wanted to disrupt and we
did this whole like fake little story
but we came on a bit thick with people
turned on them
yeah so that was I think maybe uh a
Learning lesson on our storytelling
there but yeah
I don't I like to think that wasn't the
reason he left though
he left because he had a better
opportunity it's as simple as that
yeah
and yeah I mean
it's awesome that he has built that into
such an amazing uh channel so yeah it's
just cool to see stuff pop up totally oh
yeah yeah
I also remember uh Henry from this isn't
like us he was with us but Henry from
minute physics when he was way back
today with Freddie and Brandon and he's
like I just started doing these physics
videos like it blows up to become like
one of the like top science channels on
YouTube it's crazy yeah I was just
hanging out with him in in April at
thinkercon this year last time I saw him
was the previous thinker con because he
lives up in like Montana he's kind of uh
reclusive a little bit uh
great guy I love hanging out with him it
was good to catch up with him he grew up
from uh 15 minutes away from us in
Stillwater that's crazy
like we competed on ski teams
no not at all yeah I have no
recollection of who he was so I mean I
probably never actually met him I'm just
too because yeah he was he was the one
who introduced me to Freddy and you guys
technically in person because uh he was
yeah he was working for Freddy at the
time and we've been chatting all summer
over email because I was I was a big fan
of his YouTube channel and he didn't
have many followers at all just a couple
thousand at the time
um and then when I visited L.A he's like
hey come come check it out and of course
I wasn't gonna turn that down
I don't know if you remember but when do
you remember when the keep the band that
myself Jake Jimmy and Sam were in when
we played VidCon in the arena I was
there he joined us that's right yeah I
was in the crowd
it was one of the coolest like I
remember at the time thinking like how
the hell is this so cool it was like he
just whips out this fiddle and you guys
are going back and forth between like
the Skyrim theme and what was the other
song you're playing it was like uh
the game of the Game of Thrones theme I
think but like you'd mix between the two
and he was just like on stage with his
violin
yeah he's a really good fiddle player I
also remember Jimmy uh sorry sorry I
also remember Jimmy uh going up to the
crowd and being like who wants to effing
touch me
yeah
Jimmy got like real hype on that he even
dropped the mic at the end
I'm sure the sound guy's just like this
freaking kid
he plays for some rock so expensive he
thinks he's a such a hot shot it's like
damn straight he wants to touch me as he
goes up to like the front of the crowd
they're like me
[Music]
yeah
I have a recording on my phone like we
did a rehearsal in the hotel room before
we went on stage and we didn't have any
instruments so I'm like playing drums on
the floor and Sam's playing an acoustic
guitar and Jimmy's just like acapella
singing well not acapella because we had
instruments and Henry had his fiddle and
like he bust out the craziest solos and
it's just like us staying in the hotel
room like we're finished we're like damn
this is really good you're really good
Henry he's like yeah and then like Hotel
Management's like you have to stop
playing music in here
yeah you're banging on the floor and
singing weird folk songs yeah playing
the fiddle come on that's so funny dude
yeah because I met Henry when he was
still attending USC for film school
after getting his uh I think it was his
it was either his Masters or his PhD in
physics theoretical physics uh I think
it was his Masters I'm not sure but yeah
he was at film school at USC and it was
just after I uh because I helped him out
with a film shoot while I was in LA
visiting before ever moving here and
and he I think he dropped out shortly
after that to pursue just making YouTube
videos full time he quit working for
Freddy and Brandon at the time
um yep
he went and did his collab with Stephen
Hawking
oh wait oh yeah what
wait Henry worked with Stephen Hawking
oh really yeah
yeah that one I did not know that
okay
Stephen Hawkings I don't know if he was
like an in-depth collab yeah the the Mr
you know this part one yeah
not Stephen Hawking Lynch
laughs
that's crazy I love that guy's work
that's cool Griffin that was the best
callback thank you
you know I do Wonder like let's say you
were somebody who was passionate about
making something whether it's like music
or videos or whatever but you you
weren't an on-camera person you weren't
necessarily like cut out for like being
on camera like what advice would you
have to somebody like that if they were
trying to get into
making media in this day and age
it depends what kind of content they're
making you know it's like these days you
can just write a script and have a robot
read it that's what I'm saying there's
so many ways to present your videos and
ideas now yeah I mean you wouldn't even
have to record voiceover like Ren just
said like you could have an AI or just
hire someone who does this you know a
lot of channels do that like I watch a
lot of History Channels and like most of
them
uh you know the main team is writers and
then they send it off to the vo artist
and you know they do it's like a whole
production they got and like they're
legit vo artists on all these History
Channels because you know they're just
sending off the scripts and then they
have graphics people so there's ways to
break it down it's not like the main guy
running the channel is the one in front
of the camera well I have a crazy story
about this so uh at thinkercon I was
hanging out with a small group of
YouTubers uh like I don't want to name
drop but they're like big time
educational YouTubers and it was just
kind of cool being in the circle with
them uh and then like the guy across
from me uh his name is Philip I had
never met him before thick German accent
uh very nice guy and I was like what's
your channel he's like cursed is that
and I was like what I had no idea
because they hire a voice actor to
narrate all of their uh their videos and
they have a whole it's nothing but
illustrations so he he is the owner of
the channel like he he started the
channel he was the sole worker on it for
years but he never did any of the the
voice acting so he was like purely
anonymous
which I found to be like really
fascinating because that's very rare in
YouTube these days where you have
someone behind the scenes who literally
no one knows what they look like you
have like there's like who a few of them
there's like dream I guess he had a face
reveal at some point but there's not
many others
yeah no I mean I think that's really
cool actually
kind of weird too because you're like
who's actually like behind this channel
but I don't know there's an air of music
from talking with him I started uh
recognizing his writing style just
through our conversation so I thought
that was really cool yeah we sat on a
bus for half an hour uh going to like a
baseball game and uh we sat and we just
had an awesome conversation just talking
about stuff because he's also a fan of
corridor
um and so we were able to connect really
easily and just talking about life
talking about making YouTube videos he's
he got to start basically just brute
forcing all these YouTube videos in his
free time which wasn't much while
working full-time then eventually I
think after a year or two he was doing
all this and
um these days he still does a lot of the
artwork for the videos like he kind of
does like the main illustrative sort of
design and composition but he has a
whole team of animators that goes
through and actually animates all the
stuff drops in text moves stuff off
screen uh to go along with the script
but he he has a I think he has a small
team of uh writers and editors that uh
they work on all that but yeah it's just
it was yeah it's a fascinating example
you don't have to be on camera at all to
have a very successful YouTube channel
that's that point yeah yeah that was a
very like grounded response to my
question you can do like real world
examples backing it up and everything
you can do like the Amazon Drop Shipping
equivalent of being a YouTuber where you
literally just automate the process and
you write the ideas or not even yeah and
just I mean as long as you're paying for
these people to do their jobs it's like
I mean but well yeah like this is that
kind of money connections you know what
what are you gonna like put in the work
first yeah and then then you can do it
exactly I do agree with that these days
though it's like or any more I should
say you can I always get frustrated when
I see videos popping up talking about
how to make content farms and it's like
I get what they're doing they're
basically just like oh you sign up for
uh this whatever this Chad GPT style
thing is it writes out a bunch of script
ideas writes out your script to
automates and uh gets your voice
narrated out automates generating a
bunch of background uh pictures and
videos automatically edits it all
together to the narration of your video
and and automatically exports that to a
YouTube video that it also automatically
uploads it's like
why do people think there's value in
that it's like I mean automatically make
social media posts for your business to
all these social media channels yeah do
you people read that do you think you
are doing anything productive I'm afraid
I'm afraid people would watch that stuff
because you don't know from the the like
the source like you click on a nice
interesting thumbnail or whatever and
you're listening to a realistic
charismatic voice they're getting pretty
good these days and maybe it's a little
while in you're like wait a minute
the writing is a little sus here it
seems a little
weirdly written already made their their
ad rev I feel like I see this more often
on on like Instagram or like reels type
scrolling right rather than YouTube
whether it's you know Instagram Facebook
group Tick Tock doesn't matter
um YouTube shorts as well but I feel
like YouTube shorts and all those other
platforms are the same thing whereas
YouTube is its own thing it's completely
separate
yeah even though it's obviously
technically the same
I wonder
I wonder how the shorts move is going to
work out for YouTube
so I feel like they went like you know
what people like really cheap content
that doesn't keep you coming back to any
specific Channel or platform it's like
oh boy
I don't know that yeah no I mean they're
just they're like hey look at these
other guys doing this thing let's shed
our whole identity and then try to do
that also so we can be the one doing it
instead of them I mean I've used YouTube
shorts quite a bit at this point like
especially the last like couple months
or so I've I've yeah I'm like consuming
it more uh I'll just tell me fun next
thing I know I've just been like
scrolling through posts after post after
post for half an hour I'm just like okay
yeah
that's why I tried to stop using tick
tock
I know it's I don't know I'm not sure
how I feel about that that whole like
just turn off your brain and don't watch
anything but don't do anything either
you know yeah the dopamine slot machine
gosh man I just I do Wonder like you
know as we as we progress as the stuff
that's new and edgy becomes old and
boring like
you know is like for example like life
vlogging where people just go out and do
crazy things like is that still a thing
that gets views these days or is that
like a genre that's dead I feel like
travel vloggers are very much alive I
watch a lot of it travel vlogging is
live I'm talking more about like I
filled up my house with a thousand water
balloons or like that kind of thing
dude I think it's very difficult to
break into that now yeah I think that's
the case which means that anyone who's
already there and established can
continue to do that I don't know if
their views are stagnating or not but
yeah
I am happy to see more like
to see people continue to make like
just really
weird like
low budget content where it's just like
them with a camcorder and like they
found a weird guy so they're just like
recording what he said like that's the
stuff I always loved about YouTube when
I was younger and like I kind of hope
that kind of stuff has a Renaissance
where like you know there's there's just
more like
rawness and weirdness and like yeah more
realness yeah I do feel like that's
where the pendant is swinging a little
bit at least for a bunch of audiences
like I mean that's why everybody's
always marketing movies now like there's
no CGI it's like people want that
realness now and like a world where
everything's so easy to generate and
it's also Nico said a bad word
CGI CGI
yeah
when people also want the fantasy and
escapism too I think it all just depends
on what you're searching for I think
they just yeah they just want that
they want the the fakeness with the
realness they want the fakeness
surrounded by the realness so you don't
know it's fakeness
just come on like yeah like doesn't it
can show me flashes past is that the
Polar Express like it doesn't happen
that way you know
um yeah they just want like super high
level suspension of disbelief
yeah
I mean that's all any of us want without
having to go like too far into like but
really look at how awesome this is
that's how real it is it's like
visual effects are trending into like
let's just show more more more more more
to really
digging how real and cool this is and
it's like it's having the opposite
effect on people I think like if you see
like three really good VFX shots like
old ilm 90s shots or whatever you know
like those amazing shots where
everything's crafted those tell us so
much more for your story and getting the
audience invested yeah than you know
just seeing a whole Fleet of spaceships
with the blue and the purple energy
beams and explosions and the whole
there's a guess what there's a team of
the guys that have the suits now and
they're blowing [__] up like cool great
yeah I get it thank you
that's my superhero rent for the podcast
if you're uh if you're on the bingo card
we're all patiently waiting for Grandpa
Nick to finish his superhero rant yeah
when I was your age superheroes had
names
they had leotards I Was Your Age
superheroes for their underwear on the
outside yeah and they were happy with it
dude they were so happy with it it was a
better time
yeah
if I have to see one more goddamn blue
energy explosion again I'm gonna lose my
[__] I swear to God I'm so tired of it
dude yeah man honestly I got the energy
explosions out I'm so tired of that glow
everything has the same glow these days
so it ever just uses the same glow
filter
and it's all yeah it's it's like the new
like lens flare you know or like like
Haze like it's just another compositing
piece of bull crap yeah it doesn't look
as good either yeah tell me how you
really feel you need to wrap up that
Superhero I'm done
from now on
yeah
I do I do feel like you know we're
constantly on this like what you know I
guess we would cause a treadmill of you
know content creation but at the same
time I feel like there's a lot of
moments where we pause and we make a
piece about something that's either
happened in our lives or it's happening
around us in our lives and like those
things when like when we stop to talk
about that stuff is when I feel like
they end up making stuff that's unique
and it doesn't feel like disposable
content it feels like something that's
like oh here's an important thing or
this thing like really connects and like
you feel something with it
I do feel like there's like that Avenue
also for people like in a world where it
feels like everything is done and every
story has been told and every genre
genre is filled it's like instead of
looking to the Past just look at right
now and like what's the most current
thing that's happening that people
haven't made art about that people
haven't like digested as a society and
you can help people digest it with your
digesting enzymes known as art you know
you know that's why I'm I'm very excited
for the future of like immersive content
like 3D video and whatnot especially
with like
the the Apple headset coming out next
year I mean I'm not saying I'm gonna get
it but I'm very excited for that coming
out and ushering in whatever future Tech
comes like the new iPhones I just got
announced literally this morning have uh
are gonna be able to shoot immersive
video on it so basically 3D video
somehow using the depth sensor so I'm
hoping the depth sensor isn't upgraded
uh which would mean a higher resolution
lidar I haven't actually read anything
about the new phone today uh so this is
speculation but I'm hoping it's true
because if it's a higher resolution
lidar scanner that means 3D photo scans
using our phone will be better too
awesome
dang man I'm still running my iPhone 12.
really dude Nico it's time to upgrade
they have USBC now
oh do they yeah
no
that would actually make me do it
I'm down to get away from lightning man
up until like a couple months ago Dude
and it finally bricked on me so I had to
upgrade yeah dang yeah the USBC is nice
when I like I used to do every two years
because I feel like phones were
advancing really fast and I got the
iPhone x and I kept that one for four
years and upgraded that to the 12.
mainly just to get the wide angle yeah
it's a game changer it's worth it but
you know the 12 is such a superior phone
to the X but like they're so good now
the phones are so good it's like
I don't and I don't need to upgrade I
probably shouldn't but like I yeah oh
boy I feel the exact opposite I've
upgraded every year for the last like
three years I think it's the first
because I I was also on the every other
year plane and now with the I don't know
I feel like the video capabilities and
the software capabilities of the phones
for what I do with 3D scanning and all
that stuff advances so much every year
that I'm like I have to upgrade it's
it's very easy to justify for my job and
yet you sit here and say you're not
gonna buy the Apple AR kit
we all know you are I mean it's just too
expensive it's yeah the Apple headset is
like starting 3 500 and it's like okay
that's pretty expensive
I don't I'm like I'm not gonna draw
money on that just yet despite really
wanting one and I can easily justify
getting it if I really needed it but I I
don't know yet so I'm gonna it's not
gonna be anything to do with it too
that's the other thing it's like it's
like oh I agree like I'm I'm also like
oh it's so cool camp but like the
reality is like buying the Xbox on
launch like I guess maybe there's like a
Halo but that's about it you know
Griffin just Quantified it in a way that
makes it more palatable to me personally
that is 1 000 McChickens Ren
food that you can eat in your lifetime
30. a McChicken is three and a half
dollars
dude Griffin just ruined Apple's whole
career dude like that launch is gonna be
a total failure afterward gets out you
know I was thinking that's a couple one
Wheels
uh on the wisdom of how you measure the
value of something which is a big
chickens is a great measurement value
yeah Harley was telling me a story also
about like you know first class ticket
it's like okay so you buy a ticket for
apply for my Canada to America you know
it's a couple hundred bucks upgrade to
first class for 800 or something like
that it's like it's always like this
really steep number like uh man no no
thanks and like Harley's found himself
like he's like oh oh cause he's kind of
a big guy he's like should I do it this
time should I do this time then he's
like the positive thing goes all right
the fight is like
three to four it's a four hour flight
right if somebody was like Hey Harley
can you sit in that chair for four hours
I'll give you eight hundred dollars like
then you can take your phone you can
take your switch you can take your steam
deck it doesn't matter all you have to
do is sit yeah I will bring you pop
we'll bring you some chips you'll have
to sit that chair for four hours just
for four hours we'll give you 800 he's
like I would totally do that and it's
like and when it comes to First Class
you know it's like instead like it's
something like you sit in the coach and
you save 800 sitting in that chair for
four hours and then you're like oh you
know I don't know maybe it's worth
upgrading to first class but the moment
somebody like contextualizes it is like
yeah if you're sitting like a coach
chair I'll give you 800 yeah sit there
for four hours like yeah I'll do that
I'm not spending into being given yeah
yeah essentially
yeah yeah first class I only flew first
class one time when we were a kid and
our flights got canceled so they let us
and I was like a tiny little kid so I
was like this is awesome
it was like
I rarely fly first class I recently did
flying back from North Carolina
the night after the morning after
breaking my collarbone I can't remember
if I told this story or not but oh yeah
I I was basically like
I used my points to buy a ticket back
and I went ahead and upgraded it uh so I
did all three points fortunately I
upgraded my flight to first class
because I was like all right this is a
five hour flight from North Carolina and
I am I haven't even seen a doctor yet
but my shoulder hurts and so I got the
first class that's how I was like all
right I'm gonna do that and then I'll
see my doctor in L.A did they say do
they think the X-ray on the plane like
what kind of perks did you get I mean it
was yeah
I did get escorted closer to the front
of the line because I was uh I had a
cart which had my bags in it
and I had more bags than I can really
should carry with a broken collarbone
and so once I had to get rid of the cart
to stand in line uh the one of the gate
guard ladies was like oh hell no and she
she lifted the thing and like had me run
up to the front of the line uh with the
cart I was like this is great but no the
best perk was that my my first class
tickets came with Rhett and Link
oh really what do you mean no like I sat
next to Rhett and Link on the airplane
that is really it blew my mind
yeah I'm dead serious we had an awesome
conversation out of aware North Carolina
like Raleigh North Carolina the crazy
part is that I had just flown out to to
Raleigh like two days earlier I left I
left I went to a one-wheel racing event
and I left early
but on the flight out there I was also
on the plane with Rhett and Link but I
didn't introduce myself to them uh I I
didn't they were being heckled by uh
people at the airport they're very
famous and
and so I didn't want to bother him or
anything but I walked past him they're
sitting in first class I was like oh man
five or fly first class again wouldn't
that be crazy if I sit next to them and
then they like literally happened it I
sat down I was I was one of the first
people to sit down on the airplane and
so I'm getting comfy and then sure
enough Rhett and Link sit down they were
across the aisle technically uh I was on
the right window seat and they had the
other side of the aisle and eventually
another dude sat down between us so our
conversation was cut short but we talked
for like 10 or so minutes that's how I
know that they both enjoy one-wheeling
and they actually talked about meeting
me on that airplane on one of their
podcasts like a month or so ago
I hope somebody posts this in the red
leak subreddit or whatever like hey
coroner talks about red and Link in
their podcast talked about them talking
about this on the podcast yeah
about them and their podcast
no it's super coolers can we go you see
them online and and I mean I mean we're
all familiar with this we've all met a
lot of YouTubers but they're they were
very nice they were they were cool we
talked about injuries because I just
broken my collarbone link had also just
broken his collarbone I think
unrelatedly uh there yeah so we traded
stories about injuries that was where
that
a lot of my one-wheeling conversations
with people tends to migrate towards
injuries these days which is unfortunate
but
um this is cool you know Sam and I have
been on their podcast
that's so crazy yeah I remember we're at
the freaking streamies last December and
uh we sat right next to Rhett and Link's
table yeah and I was sitting literally
like
feet from link and I remember him
leaning over uh tapping Christian's
shoulder and pointing at you Nico and
being like hey I know that guy
well they're just like you know they're
old OG YouTube sorry guys
universe
look you know from the mouth of babes
right
but uh yeah you know it's like they've
been around since the beginning and it's
just like it's there's a couple that
have been and it's just cool to see each
other at you know another streamies
another year another yeah step down the
road it's like all right you guys are
still doing it still hanging they're
always very easy to see at the streamies
because they're taller than everyone all
right
yeah
especially with his hair going on like
it's like a whole thing a red and Link
our generation's Penn and Teller
uh they are definitely the best duo to
capitalize on an ampersand between their
names yeah they're like iconic Ampersand
buds for sure
Nico Channel
yeah I guess you know what I guess you
guys were through the salmon Eagle
Channel yeah the salmon Eagle Channel
yeah I love that you have to pronounce
the L with it otherwise it sounds too
much like the original name
it is crazy that you just said like I
was thinking today about like how big
and yet small the world is you know just
like in Los Angeles you'll run into your
friends on the street you know you'll
run to people you know or like literally
at the airport or on a plane yeah in
another spot of the country you'll run
into somebody or like when Ivy and I
were doing our honeymoon in France we
did a wine Chateau tour and then like
four days later we were in a different
part of the country at a market and the
person standing in front of us in line
to buy some food was our tour guide from
the castle two or five days ago on the
other side of France and it's like hi
what are you doing here wow yeah it's so
it's so strange wow like the world
really is a small place it's not as big
as we think but at the same time you
like you watch a movie and like the
whole universe like will exist but like
the six main characters somehow run into
each other all the time yeah unrealistic
yeah yeah like playing playing Zelda and
like constantly talking to the king and
queen it's like do they ever do anything
else in this Kingdom like are there any
citizens in this Kingdom or is it just
the king and queen living in this entire
kingdom do they have any day business or
is it just standing around talking to
you know Princess Zelda who is it that
described here like my whole kingdom and
there's like four peasants
I'm going about like two guards it's
like ah you've saved the realm
we didn't Sam describe like breath of
the wild tears of the Kingdom as
basically being uh Society run by
toddlers
that was me that was you
yeah it's basically everybody's it's
right though it's like everything's just
very simplified yeah everything's been
nerfed like everybody's like
intelligence the maturity they're like
the danger they're in it's all been
nerfed across the board everybody's like
at about like the level like of like a
five or six year old like they're really
into their stuff and they really want to
be friends and they want to be do nice
things which is great but yeah I mean
that's classic Nintendo I guess yeah of
the day yeah it's definitely wholesome
oh dude I finally beat tears of the
Kingdom by the way I did the I fought
Gannon
thank you very much
no spoilers I'm I'm gonna get there I'm
not I'm not saying anymore I'm just
saying it was like it was it was so much
better than breath of the wild like as a
final sequence of events it was and then
the last event was it just blew my mind
it was because I had been putting it off
because I didn't like I don't like how
Nintendo does that thing where it's like
you're not able to exist in a post-ganon
world so it's like you beat the game but
then you have to just reload the game
right before you jump into the pit and
it's like it feels very unrewarding to
walk away from that knowing you've
already beaten it but like in game in
this universe you're like no
and like turning away from the final
boss it does give you an asterisk on
your save file but I don't know
yeah that yeah I agree the Ganondorf
fight in the first breath of the wild
was uh
a little underwhelming it was kind of
good this one is not here's the kingdom
is not
Jane and I both fought Gannon or did the
Ganon sequence at the same time while
waiting in line to get out of uh burning
man because we sat within like this Four
Mile stretch of road for like eight
hours to get out we got in line at like
eight we didn't get out until 8 PM sorry
noon didn't get out until 8 pm
yeah I always played a lot
I was making really good progress
towards like I'm close to the end I'm
probably like maybe two or three hours
away from doing the Ganondorf battle and
like I was making really good progress
and I was on top of like this one style
and and Milo my daughter who was
watching plays like can you can you go
over there and there's just like a
little island out in the ocean I'm like
I probably could she's like you should
do it I'm like
all right and just jump off the island
and then you know I'm like eight hours
into that little island adventure by the
way
it's been a whole journey and it's
really sidelined mine but is that that
Island down in the bottom right of the
map
yeah there's like the Pirate's Cove and
there's a city yeah I've done that yeah
yeah so it's been a good time but it
really it really derailed my progress
thanks Milo
yeah
I'll never forget us playing on uh your
your work switch because you have two
switches now we're playing smash
upstairs and all of a sudden it goes to
the main screen being like two accounts
are playing this game right now and
you're like uh-oh I think Milo just
turned on my switch at home and we're
all just like on a break going oh yeah
none of us can play and Abby said that
it was actually Calvin had pulled it out
and uh she said that like it was like a
minute later he had put it back and they
turned it off so if we would have stuck
around for like a few more seconds it
would have worked for us that's how it
goes though
yeah
uh you know it's almost Smash season
again
I forgot about it wow Ren who's your
favorite to win this year
me I can't say that
uh honestly I think Griffin
are you sure you sure about that no of
course I'm not I'm never sure
I appreciate the vote of confidence
though that means a lot don't I'm gonna
I'm gonna beat you pretty bad
how about you Griffin who would you
favor this year
well
it's not my favorite but I like I don't
like it but I feel like Jordan Allen has
a pretty good chance again dude if he
becomes the first time to win it twice
I'll be so I mean honestly I'll be mad
if anyone wins it twice before me
yeah I kind of I might agree with you
especially if you play Samus but yeah oh
he's gonna play Samus and he's gonna
play super super careful
oh you can't you can't waffle out like
that you gotta give me a prediction
Christian just throw a name out there
does Christian have a my queen no he
doesn't but I'm just gonna interrupteen
he says Dean how are you Nick you don't
have anything yeah no I think uh it's
gonna be I think it's gonna be Sam
yeah uh unfortunately said Matt no you
know it could be Matt's here wait this
is Matt's here yeah this is Matt's here
you know what Matt see there it is yeah
yeah yes it's gonna be messy ultimate
for Matt I'll root for Matt yeah the
thing about Dean I I recognize there's a
bunch of similarities between Dean and
some of the top one wheel Racers where
it's like
they're the favorite to win and they
never do
that
technically Dean has one
early days of us playing when he first
joined up but he hasn't won since
I'm team Matt all the way from now on
all right Nick's room for Matt I like
this everybody lives in this podcast is
like oh my God they're talking about
Smash Brothers again but listen guys we
have put a lot of time into Smash
Brothers it's like perhaps making videos
is our first mission here at cordhorn
Smash Brothers is our second
oh you want to hear a cool engineering
project idea I have
yeah
it has to do with Smash Bros and burning
man so apologies for continuing to talk
about burning man everybody's out now
nobody's listening to the podcast
anymore it's an art cars uh situation
where you can play Smash it's two
different cars one which has a giant
flatbed truck that has a giant uh
projector screen on it that swivels
around an axis so it can turn and
there's another car that's just a giant
sofa it's just a giant couch enough to
sit like a couple like like a dozen
people like a lounge car uh and they're
both driving down like through the
desert or whatever just randomly you
have the switch and all the controllers
on the couch with a a wireless video
link to the projector screen on the
truck but they're always turning so it
doesn't matter where the cars are
driving they'll always be pointed at
each other to just keep them perfectly
dude no no because they both wrote the
couch rotates and the screen rotates so
depending on where they are they'll
always be pointed at each other so you
could just be riding through the Via and
just like be playing smash jump up on a
couch play Smash
I love this idea because amazing I get
the feeling that like like five years
from now like burning man 2028 I'm gonna
be there I'm gonna be like three days
into like a desert walk I'm gonna be
like slowly losing my sense of identity
in my sanity I'm gonna be like it's look
and then like I'm just gonna see people
play I'm just gonna hear the smash theme
and then you're gonna be there and
you'll be like hey you wanna you wanna
play a quick three and I'll be like
no you'll just hear this across the play
it'll just be like you hear a clap
I'm like seven hours into like a
meditation there's huh
guys I'll be back gotta smash yeah I'll
be back in 20 minutes
yeah sick that's sweet dude so that's my
idea for like an art car I think that'd
be really cool to do but yeah I don't
know who the hell's gonna pay for that
not me I think I think that delightful
imagery is what we can
resolve this yeah this uh podcast with
so yeah
um it's reaching that time guys the
witching hour here at Corridor the
witching hour
yeah this is a fun like um
to end this podcast I don't want to talk
too much about this but Nico Nick
the float wheel
yes I don't want to talk about it much I
don't want to talk about it much just
yet at least but I did finally get my
float wheel working today
yes I can't wait Ren let's go riding
maybe not tonight maybe tomorrow yeah
but uh yeah like I'm sure once again
this is gonna be a niche audience thing
but we did do our one our vesque podcast
like a year ago and now we can follow up
with the float wheel podcast I've got
over 100 miles on my board uh I've been
over 100 miles in less than a week
yeah it was great I love it um I've been
uh trying to convert everybody in the
office to get one
um nick uh Phill included yeah yeah my
pride I uh I got a new little Loot drop
on the way in China so I'm looking
forward to that one yeah yeah I did that
well I was like look like my XR I've
been riding it for like four or more
years now yeah six years if you've had
that XR a long time I have one wheel
that long it's been a long time that
thing is like it's done me good yeah and
now you know I've been thinking about a
GT for a while but then I tried Nico's
the other night at Verdugo the flute
wheel oh my gosh yeah it was just like
another level from the GT
it's cheaper and I'm gonna be able to
customize it for like ever and like have
full ability to you know keep adding and
changing up parts and stuff so I mean
Parts you get from China
it'll be it'll take a while to get there
that's why you gotta switch them out you
know like hey you know what yeah but to
be fair like you know you can use any
Tire once again it's back to a six inch
highlight instead of a proprietary six
and a half inch hubs now you can easily
Tire again I bought a seven inch tire
there you go look at that a seven inch
tire which is barely fits wow yeah so
the idea and the benefit of a larger
tire is that uh it goes over more stuff
and there's more sidewalls so it has
like a lot more cushion to it so it
should feel a little less like uh
shock shocky it should absorb more
impact in and I'm hoping it has like a
nicer like feel to it I don't know I'm
getting the tire just because I really
want to try the big tire gang uh so I'm
gonna I'm gonna try putting that on but
I I haven't even ridden the the float
wheel yet I just got it all like tuned
and bounced which was the whole thing I
had to I had to do the IMU calibration
five times
but then you gotta figure it out yeah
I've never built a one wheel before so
you'll have a great time yeah it's
actually it's really awesome it makes
you feel like you're like really cool
and getting into some cool stuff oh my
gosh dude yeah I mean haven't building a
one wheel on the floor while there's AI
stuff processing
in the background is like one of the
most like 2023 things you can do yeah
I'm there for it building in one wheel
you bought using crypto
uh yeah right I will say for for anybody
listening who's got a one-wheeler is
thinking about getting a float wheel or
upgrading to a GT or anything like the
float wheel has been a delight it's it
is like riding a missile it it's I think
it's a six horsepower machine the GT is
a three horsepower machine like doing 20
miles an hour going up a hill and like
the board has Headroom still is a very
strange feeling what I've never felt
before like I I'm the board has I mean I
never like I want to say like it
rekindled my love for like riding one
Wheels because like it's not like that
love like went out yeah like I still
really liked doing it but I'll just say
that when I got the float wheel I was
right I'm writing every night I'm out
every night doing at least like three
four miles so wow yeah it's uh it's
giving you a new a new lot on one-wheel
life basically a new yeah exactly Kindle
the flame in no it's that's awesome I
can't wait man would you recommend it
for beginners or do you think it's more
of it I do feel like anybody who's if
it's if you want to get a wheel for the
very first time I'd recommend getting a
future motion wheel like yeah with like
a pint a pint it's definitely safer a
used XR I would say it used XR over a
pint I'm not a big fan of like that
smaller platform yeah I used XR on
honestly I think is like one of the best
deals you can get these days even to use
GT
yeah yeah either one is like the GT is
still a great one wheel it's still a
great one yeah be ready to sell it in a
year and buy a float wheel I won't say
that
but one wheel's really holding value
yeah yeah you can you can probably buy
your XR and sell your XR for like within
a hundred dollars the price you buy it
for they're hopefully releasing custom
shaping soon which will have some uh
vesque features like turn tilt and or
they call them different things but a
few things like that are being
incorporated into the GT now which I
think is very good
yeah and that's cool I mean at least the
thing I'm really excited about the float
wheel is that like
if a module breaks or it dies or gets
upgraded I can just buy another brain I
can buy another battery box I can buy
different rails I can swap things out I
can buy a new motor I could buy a motor
for each tire if I wanted to so that if
I want to swap a tire I just unplug one
motor and plug another one in and then
keep riding
um there's so many ways you can approach
it and you can do this with vesque as
well of course
um but it just it helps to have
something out there that kind of
standardizes stuff just a little bit
like the XR is kind of like that and now
we have at least something else
comparable with like the float wheel
because my my vest has been dead for a
while because I have to like open it up
and do some wiring in my closet
yeah it's in my house right now okay uh
he has some skeletons in this closet
specifically skeletons on my one Wheels
um
but like you know just taking the you
know four to five to six hours to deal
with that you know Apartments you have
to order the parts ahead of time like I
just haven't done it it's just having
the float wheel show up I assemble it
and I ride it it's really great if
something breaks swap the part out yeah
done get back on it yeah I love it I
love it so much we'll talk about it more
in another podcast once friends ridden
his abundance once I get some experience
and have some thoughts yeah and Griffin
there's gonna be a lot of uh extra
boards floating around now we'll have
new ones so when you uh when you decide
I might I might take you up on that but
uh I kind of I decided in 2019 that
maybe one Wheeling isn't for me because
the I think third time I set foot on one
I crashed it directly into Clint's Puget
I was like maybe this isn't for me dude
wait his yeah
what this Pokemon his
Beauties
no he crashed into his Puget
oh it's computer right I was thinking
like cars
was
yeah that's how I knew
well we have plenty of extras if you
ever want to learn I'll let you borrow
one yeah and look Clint's not here
anymore and he don't got no Pokemons
here so yeah
also let me take this opportunity to
pressure Christian again hey Christian
you should get a float wheel they're
great yeah get some crypto buy some usdc
baby
sell your XR
turn that into crypto
oh yeah that's true you always have
audio board
all right I do actually have to go I
have to get home and make dinner
family oh it was uh thanks for hanging
with us all your podcast listeners those
are fun yeah very casual just yeah Wren
Griff Nick it was a delight yeah dude
right on over man I will okay Pros lots
of Pros in the float world only cons
it's heavy heavy because the tire and
the heaviest isn't the worst it's really
not all that bad but it is heavy uh the
tire is also very wide and square
meaning that if you're on something
that's kind of like slanted to the side
the board has a tendency to want to roll
or be Tippy as people might describe it
I have since dropped the board one notch
down so the board is actually a bit
lower one of the other perks about it
being a float wheel and it is much more
stable but once I swap into a new tire
it's more rounded it should completely
solve the issue
yeah
it does however rip on streets yeah okay
that's it oh and new lifetime record of
25.9 miles an hour
all right guys have a good one see ya
see you later and three two one